انا الان من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي الياسحنا ست العميد نهايه
الحرب اوائل الصيف المقبل تقول
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه ربما هل تعتقد ان
هذا همم وارد ام انها ربما امنيه بعيده
المناهل
عثمان نتذكر بدايه الحرب كان الموضوع مده
اسبوع اسبوعين تسقط كل اوكرانيا وها نحن
على همم سنه من الحرب اليوم الواقع
السياسي مرتبط بالانجازات العسكريه على
الارض اثنين مرتبط باهداف الافريقاء لان
ذلك في مرحله المكسيمالست يعني الحد
الاقصى يريد الرئيس بوتين والحد الاقصى
يريد الرئيس وبالتالي لا احد قادر على
الجلوس على طاوله مفاوضات طاوله المفاوضات
تحتم ان يشعر كل فريق انه حقق او هذا اقصى
ما يمكن له ان يحقق ويجب ان يباع ويسوق
هذا الامر على ال- ال- ال- الراي العام
الداخلي الاوكراني كما روسي ممكن ولكن كل
الامر متعلق بما سيحدث على الارض عثمان
نعم فيما يتعالى بقرار التعبئه الذي كشف
عنه الرئيس الاوكراني ما الذي اا سيغيره
على على الارض العميد
ازدهار اليوم هناك مشروع كامل متكامل
وخلال حرب تدور هذا هذه امور صعبه
رئيس الوزير الدفاع الروسي يقول زياده
عديد القوات المسلحه من مليون و350,000
الى مليون و500,000 حتى تغيير القطاعات
العسكريه والتدريب على مستوى متقدم وحتى
خلق جديده على منطقه كاريه على الحدود مع
فنلندا بعد ما قررت فنلندا الانضمام الى
حلف الناتو هذا مشروع كبير جدا ولكن هذا
الامر يتطلب القدره على التعبئه القدره
على التجهيز القدره على التدريب على
الحروب الحديثه او ما يسمى كومبايند ارمز
ارمي وهذه مشكله كانت اساسيه في القتال
لدى الجيش الروسي حتى اللوجستيه وحتى
الانتشار وما شابه فاذا اليوم نحن في
مرحله قد تؤثر على الماده البعيد ولكن هذا
امر يتطلب جهود كبيره خاصه والحرب دائره
بشكل همم يعني دموي كثير والان سياده
العميد برلين تقول انها لن تعارض ان تسلم
بولندا دبابات ليوباردي اثنان لاوكرانيا
اذا كانت هي لا تعارض ان تسلم بولندا
اوكرانيا هذه الدبابات فلماذا لا تسلمها
هي بشكل مباشر
همم عثمان هذه الدبلوماسيه غير مباشره
ولكن المهم بهذا الحديث مصدر ومستوى الذي
اتى منه هذا الخبر وزيره خارجيه هذا الامر
يجب ان يكون ملصقا مع المستشار الالماني
وبالتالي هو اختبار للراي العام الالماني
الداخليه وهو تهدئه للحلفاء والبارحه
راينا ماذا قال وزير الخارج وزير رئيس
الوزراء البولندي انه قد نضطر الى تحالف
معين نقط الدبابات حتى لو قبلت او عارضت
همم
المانيا انا اعتقد نحن في مسار اعطاء
الدبابات ولكن من دوله غير المانيا
شكرا جزيلا لك من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي الياسحما